Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a biweekly podcast from the American Psychological Association that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna. Have you ever met a person who experienced a tragedy, losing their home in a hurricane, and during the death of a child, having a severe illness? And yet they seemed happy, content even, truly content, and not in a way that suggested that they were bearing their feelings or minimizing their pain. experiencing positive transformation after trauma is known as post-traumatic growth. Though the concept is not new, it's been found in literature, philosophy, and religion in almost all cultures throughout the ages, the academic theory was developed by psychologists Dr. Richard Tedeschi and Dr. Lawrence Calhoun in the mid-1990s. People who experience post-traumatic growth may develop a new appreciation of life, newfound personal strength, see an improvement in their relationships, see new possibilities in life, and undergo spiritual
您好，欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会推出的双周播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳。你是否见过这样的人：他们经历过悲剧，比如在飓风中失去了家园，经历了丧子之痛，或者患有严重的疾病？然而，他们看起来却很幸福，甚至感到满足，是真正意义上的满足，而且这种满足感并非源于他们压抑情感或淡化痛苦。在创伤后经历积极的转变被称为“创伤后成长”。虽然这个概念并不新鲜，在历代几乎所有文化的文学、哲学和宗教中都能找到，但其学术理论是由心理学家理查德·特德斯基博士和劳伦斯·卡尔霍恩博士在20世纪90年代中期提出的。经历创伤后成长的人可能会对生活产生新的感悟，获得新的个人力量，改善人际关系，看到生活中的新可能性，并经历精神上的
changes. Why do some people experience such profound positive changes after enduring something terrible, and others don't? Here to help explain post-traumatic growth is Dr. Tedeski, Professor Emeritus of the University of North Carolina at Charlotte. He's a faculty member at the university's Post-Thrmatic Growth Research Group, and he's the distinguished chair at the Boulder Crest Institute for Post-Thrmatic Growth, a nonprofit organization, focused on military members, veterans, and their families. Welcome, Dr. Tedeski. Glad to be here. Good to be talking to you. Same here. The website for the Post-Tramatic Growth Research Group explains explicitly that just because a person experiences post-traumatic growth, it doesn't
变化。为什么有些人能在经历可怕的事情后获得如此深刻的积极转变，而另一些人却不能？今天，北卡罗来纳大学夏洛特分校的荣誉退休教授特德斯基博士将为我们解读创伤后成长。他是该校“创伤后成长研究小组”的成员，也是博尔德克雷斯特创伤后成长研究所的杰出主席，该研究所是一家专注于军人、退伍军人及其家庭的非营利组织。欢迎您，特德斯基博士。很高兴来到这里。很高兴能与您交谈。我也是。创伤后成长研究小组的网站明确解释说，一个人经历创伤后成长，并不
mean they won't suffer or experience pain or other negative emotions. Can you elaborate on the importance of allowing yourself to feel those negative emotions that accompany experiencing a tragedy? Post-traumatic growth starts with, of course, something. that's very aversive for people and generally not something that people are trying to invite into their lives. And it's important to acknowledge that as if we're trying to move towards eventual post-traumatic growth, we have to recognize that these events have really challenged the way we think about our lives and our anticipations of what's going to be happening in our lives. So that initial phase of looking at
意味着他们就不会遭受痛苦或经历其他负面情绪。您能详细说明一下，允许自己感受伴随悲剧而来的那些负面情绪为何如此重要吗？创伤后成长当然始于某种对人们来说非常厌恶的事情，通常也不是人们想要邀请到自己生活中的事情。重要的是要承认，如果我们试图走向最终的创伤后成长，我们必须认识到，这些事件确实挑战了我们对生活的思考方式以及我们对未来生活中将要发生之事的预期。因此，最初阶段审视
at what's happened and how it's distressed and disturbed our lives is important part of the change that comes in the future. So that's part of the answer in terms of why it's important for post-traumatic growth. But of course, trauma researchers and clinicians for many years have acknowledged that facing up to things rather than avoiding them is almost always the way to some kind of healing in the future. And when we avoid facing up to the things that have hurt us, we're probably just delaying a process where we're going to have to do it down the road anyway in some other form. I imagine it's very difficult when you're dealing with a traumatic situation to go through
发生了什么，以及这些事情如何困扰和扰乱了我们的生活，是未来变革的重要组成部分。所以，这就是为什么它对创伤后成长很重要的部分答案。当然，创伤研究人员和临床医生多年来一直承认，面对问题而不是逃避问题，几乎总是通往未来某种治愈的途径。当我们逃避面对那些伤害我们的事情时，我们可能只是在推迟一个过程，而这个过程迟早还是会以某种其他形式出现。我想，当你处理创伤性情况时，经历
that grief and those really difficult emotions. For some people, it might be a natural process. Others, it might not be natural. They may seek refuge in, you know, hiding their feelings and other coping mechanisms that may not be helpful. What do you advise people as they go through a tragedy? What are the first steps they should be going through as they go as they go through something awful? Well, as I was just saying, of course, the initial reactions and perhaps even pretty far down the road in the aftermath of tragedy are pretty unpleasant and people want to avoid unpleasant things. So one of the things that people need to do is figure out how to take a dose of this misery, approach it and face up to it, but also at times find some relief from it temporarily
那种悲伤和那些非常困难的情绪是非常艰难的。对有些人来说，这可能是一个自然的过程。对另一些人来说，可能并非如此。他们可能会寻求避难，你知道，隐藏自己的感受，或者使用其他可能无济于事的应对机制。当人们经历悲剧时，您有什么建议？当他们经历可怕的事情时，他们应该采取的第一步是什么？嗯，正如我刚才所说，当然，最初的反应，甚至在悲剧发生后的很长一段时间里，都是非常令人不快的，人们想要逃避不愉快的事情。所以人们需要做的一件事是，弄清楚如何接受这种痛苦，接近它并面对它，但同时也要找到暂时缓解它的方法，
to kind of gather themselves if they can. And in order to do that, one of the things that helps most people is to find other people who can be supportive of them and help guide them through this, distract them at times, do things for them at times if they're feeling like they can't manage certain parts of their lives in the aftermath of what's happened. So looking around and trying to find other people who they can count on is an important step early on in the process and recognizing that you have to alternate between facing what has happened and gaining some temporary relief from. the misery of it as well.
如果可以的话，让自己恢复一下。为了做到这一点，对大多数人最有帮助的事情之一是找到能够支持他们的人，帮助引导他们度过难关，有时分散他们的注意力，如果他们觉得在事情发生后无法处理生活的某些部分，就为他们做些事情。因此，环顾四周，试着找到可以依靠的人，是这个过程早期的一个重要步骤，并且要认识到，你必须在面对所发生的事情和从痛苦中获得暂时缓解之间进行交替。
So can you oscillate between the negative emotions associated with the trauma and the positive emotions associated with post-traumatic growth? Eventually, although that doesn't happen usually right away down the road where people start to notice that there has been something of value in this experience. They can certainly oscillate back and forth between those two things. But early on, you know, people, whatever they're going through, whether it's a diagnosis of cancer, a natural disaster where they've lost a lot, a bereavement experience, combat trauma, whatever it might be, they're mostly trying to survive it. They're usually not in the immediate aftermath thinking of growth at all.
那么，你可以在与创伤相关的负面情绪和与创伤后成长相关的积极情绪之间摇摆吗？最终可以，尽管这通常不会立即发生，但在一段时间后，人们开始注意到这种经历中确实存在某种价值。他们当然可以在这两者之间来回摇摆。但在早期，你知道，无论人们正在经历什么，无论是癌症诊断、失去很多的自然灾害、丧亲之痛、战斗创伤，无论是什么，他们大多是在试图生存。在紧随其后的阶段，他们通常根本不会考虑成长。
They're thinking of how to cope with their difficult emotions and what they've lost and how they're hurting. So the first thing on their agenda is survival, not growth, in the early stages of this. Down the road somewhere in reflection, they might notice that some new developments have occurred in their lives that they value. And that doesn't mean that it wipes out all of what's been difficult and miserable about their experience, but it can make all that misery something that has had some kind of purpose or value. It's not in vain.
他们考虑的是如何应对困难的情绪，以及他们失去了什么和他们有多痛苦。因此，在这一阶段的早期，他们议程上的第一件事是生存，而不是成长。在未来的某个时刻，通过反思，他们可能会注意到生活中出现了一些他们所珍视的新发展。这并不意味着它抹去了他们经历中所有困难和痛苦的部分，但它可以使所有这些痛苦变得具有某种目的或价值。它不是徒劳的。
And is it possible to regress from post-traumatic growth? Well, in our research, we've seen that there are different trajectories of growth. There are different ways that we see people proceed from initial trauma across months and years through to growth. Not everybody experiences post-traumatic growth. And some people who seem to report it early on moderate it later on or seem to have some decrement later on. And it's an interesting thing that we see these differences among people. And one of the things that you have to look at is the particulars of a person's life and what's happening. And some people who – and it's not a large number, but in the people who initially report growth and then later on less so, the interesting question is, you know, why is that happening?
那么，创伤后成长有可能倒退吗？嗯，在我们的研究中，我们发现成长的轨迹各不相同。我们看到人们从最初的创伤到最终的成长，经历了几个月甚至几年的不同过程。并非每个人都会经历创伤后成长。有些人似乎在早期报告了成长，但后来有所减弱，或者在后期似乎出现了一些退步。我们观察到人们之间存在这些差异，这是一件有趣的事情。你需要审视的是一个人的生活细节以及正在发生的事情。有些人——虽然人数不多，但在那些最初报告有成长，后来却减少的人中，有趣的问题是，你知道，为什么会发生这种情况？
What happened to them? What might have changed that? So you have to look at individuals' lives in order to kind of get at that. It could be other traumatic experiences have occurred. It could be that they've lost support. You have to look at what might be the particular factors for people that might result in growth first being apparent and then not so much later on. Some people have also said that if you look at how. people report post-traumatic growth. Some people might initially have kind of rushed into it in
他们发生了什么？是什么导致了这种变化？所以你必须审视个人的生活才能弄清楚这一点。可能是发生了其他创伤性经历。可能是他们失去了支持。你必须看看对人们来说，可能导致成长最初显现而后来却不那么明显的具体因素是什么。有些人还说，如果你看看人们如何报告创伤后成长，有些人可能最初以某种方式匆忙进入了它，
certain ways without really processing their trauma effectively enough. And therefore, you know, later on, they're going to have to do some reprocessing of this. And that's what you're getting later when they're still running into some difficulties. So it's a very series of trajectories that you can see in people. And there are a lot of individual differences in how this experience of growth occurs. So you've mentioned that post-traumatic growth is not universal and it doesn't happen for everyone. What kind of person is most likely to experience post-traumatic growth? Are there a personality traits that factor in? Well, we have found that there's some personality traits that are correlated with post-traumatic growth. For example, if you look at the
而没有真正有效地处理他们的创伤。因此，你知道，后来他们将不得不对这些进行一些重新处理。这就是你后来看到他们仍然遇到一些困难的原因。所以，你在人们身上看到的轨迹是非常多样的。这种成长体验的发生方式存在很多个体差异。您提到创伤后成长并非普遍存在，也不是每个人都会发生。什么样的人最有可能经历创伤后成长？是否有相关的人格特质？嗯，我们发现确实有一些人格特质与创伤后成长相关。例如，如果你看看
the so-called Big Five personality traits. One called openness to experience seems to be correlated with growth. And that's the kind of person who kind of invites novelty, is curious about things, eager to try new things. Of course, we could think about traumatic events as novel experiences or new things in a person's life, unfortunate as they are, but people are open to experience might be better able to do something with that. Another trait that seems to be connected with post-traumatic growth is extraversion, and there are two aspects of extroversion that seem to be perhaps most directly related to post-traumatic growth. One is activity level. People with extroversion are higher an activity,
所谓的“大五人格特质”。其中一种被称为“对经验的开放性”，似乎与成长相关。这类人通常会拥抱新鲜事物，对事物充满好奇，渴望尝试新事物。当然，我们可以把创伤性事件视为一个人生活中的新奇体验或新事物，尽管它们是不幸的，但对经验开放的人可能更有能力利用这些经历做些什么。另一种似乎与创伤后成长相关的特质是“外向性”，外向性中有两个方面似乎与创伤后成长最为直接相关。一个是活动水平。外向性较高的人活动水平也较高，
and therefore they're more likely to try to do something or take action in the aftermath of trauma, which can be a healing thing. And the second is seeking social support or seeking out other people, being comfortable, being around other people, which is, of course, another thing that we found makes positive difference and encourages the post-traumatic growth process. I want to take a deeper dive into those five areas of post-traumatic growth that I listed in the intro. Can you describe them in greater detail? These five areas of post-traumatic growth are empirically defined.
因此，他们更有可能在创伤后尝试做些什么或采取行动，这可能是一种治愈行为。第二个是寻求社会支持或寻找他人，乐于与他人相处，这当然是我们发现的另一个产生积极影响并促进创伤后成长过程的因素。我想深入探讨我在引言中列出的创伤后成长的五个领域。您能更详细地描述一下它们吗？这五个创伤后成长领域是经验性定义的。
We did some factor analytic studies, which means that we took large groups of people to report growth and looked at the kind of combination of statements that they made about growth. And through some statistical analyses, we were able to group these or cluster these statements. and they sort of created these five different categories that we named. So we didn't have preconceived notions about what these areas of growth would be until we really paid close attention to what people were telling us and subjected to some analyses. So, for example, one thing that people may report in the aftermath of trauma is that getting through the whole experience,
我们进行了一些因素分析研究，这意味着我们选取了大量报告有成长的人群，并观察了他们关于成长的陈述组合。通过一些统计分析，我们能够将这些陈述进行分组或聚类。它们最终形成了我们命名的这五个不同的类别。所以，在真正仔细倾听人们告诉我们的内容并进行分析之前，我们并没有关于这些成长领域会是什么的先入之见。例如，人们在创伤后可能会报告的一件事是，度过了整个经历，
they discovered they were stronger than they thought they were, a sense that if I can get through this, I can get through anything. So we label this personal strength. So one of the things that people can appreciate about themselves is that they have coped well, that they have survived all this, that they recognize that they have more capability and they realized about themselves before they were challenged in this way. So that may be one way people describe their growth experience.
他们发现自己比想象中更坚强，有一种“如果我能挺过这一关，我就能挺过任何事情”的感觉。所以我们将此标记为“个人力量”。因此，人们可以对自己欣赏的一点是，他们应对得很好，他们挺过了这一切，他们认识到自己拥有比在受到这种挑战之前所意识到的更多的能力。所以这可能是人们描述他们成长经历的一种方式。
And there are different constellations of reports of growth so that some people only report one type of growth. Other people report all these five. Some people report some of them. It varies a lot. But not everybody is reporting all these five areas. A second area that people talk about is how they are relating to others in a more positive way. So, for example, they may be more compassionate towards others, more open in their emotional expressions. And these changes in relationships may come out of the experience of receiving social support and compassion from other people.
关于成长的报告有不同的组合，有些人只报告一种类型的成长。其他人报告了所有这五个。有些人报告了其中一些。差异很大。但并非每个人都报告了所有这五个领域。人们谈论的第二个领域是他们如何以更积极的方式与他人相处。例如，他们可能对他人更富有同情心，在情感表达上更开放。这些人际关系的变化可能源于在经历中获得他人的社会支持和同情。
And it may also come out of recognizing how hard life can be in the aftermath of some adversity and being a little bit more forgiving and compassionate for other people who've gone through a tough times themselves, maybe not being so judgmental. So going through trauma is kind of a lesson in what it means to be human. And so this shows up in people treating their relationships with others with more care. A third area that we have described is something we call new possibilities. And that means that people uncover new pathways in their lives or new things that they can do or new priorities. What happens with some people in the aftermath of trauma is things that they thought were important,
这也可能源于认识到在经历了一些逆境后生活是多么艰难，从而对那些同样经历过艰难时刻的人更加宽容和富有同情心，也许不再那么爱评判他人。因此，经历创伤是一种关于“身为人类意味着什么”的课程。所以这体现在人们以更多的关怀对待他们与他人的关系上。我们描述的第三个领域是我们所说的“新的可能性”。这意味着人们在生活中发现了新的路径，或者他们可以做的新事情，或者新的优先事项。在创伤后，有些人会发生这样的情况：他们曾经认为重要的事情，
longer seem important to them or things that they were able to do before they're no longer able to do. So certain possibilities are kind of shut down for them and they have to explore other ways of living their lives. This was especially true of, for example, people that we had studied early on who had suffered some physical disability in adulthood. They'd become paralyzed or blinded, and it made them have to rethink how they were living and what they could do. And in the process, they struck out onto new paths and new interests and new capabilities that they may not have entertained before. And so these new possibilities sometimes emerge in people's lives.
不再对他们重要了，或者他们以前能做的事情现在不能做了。因此，某些可能性对他们来说被关闭了，他们必须探索其他的生活方式。这对于我们早期研究的那些在成年后遭受某种身体残疾的人来说尤其如此。他们瘫痪或失明了，这使他们不得不重新思考他们是如何生活的以及他们能做什么。在这个过程中，他们开辟了新的道路，产生了新的兴趣和新的能力，这些可能是他们以前从未考虑过的。所以这些新的可能性有时会出现在人们的生活中。
Another area that people reported to us is something that we called appreciation of life. And so you get this when people are saying things like, for example, I came close to death, and now I have a second chance. I'm living on borrowed time. This is my new life that I easily could not have had, so I really appreciate the fact that I've got this opportunity. So that might be one way. Another way people express this is by saying that they might have. have taken things for granted before, and now they're more appreciative of what they have in their lives and don't just gloss over things anymore. And then the final area that we've looked at that people have reported to us is what we've called spiritual and existential growth. Sometimes this comes out as a deepened investment in religious life. Other times it can be a change, in people's perspective on what they consider to be the spiritual world. Other times it could be an enhanced ability or interest in grappling with existential questions
人们向我们报告的另一个领域是我们所说的“对生活的欣赏”。当你听到人们说类似这样的话时，你就会明白这一点：例如，我曾濒临死亡，现在我有了第二次机会。我是在借来的时间里生活。这是我本可能不会拥有的新生活，所以我真的很感激我有这个机会。这可能是一种方式。人们表达这一点的另一种方式是说，他们以前可能把事情视为理所当然，而现在他们更欣赏生活中拥有的东西，不再只是敷衍了事。我们研究的最后一个领域是人们向我们报告的，我们称之为“精神和存在主义成长”。有时这表现为对宗教生活投入的加深。另一些时候，它可能是人们对他们所认为的精神世界的视角发生了变化。另一些时候，它可能是处理存在主义问题的能力或兴趣的增强，
like the meaning of life, the purpose of life, the degree to which all people are bound together, what are the universal themes in living a human life and being human. sort of philosophical questions almost, but these questions have become actually practically significant because of the trauma that people have faced. Now they have to, they've naturally started rethinking what's the point of living? What am I supposed to be doing with my time here on earth? Asking those kinds of questions and trying to get a handle on how to live well and wisely. So those are generally the five areas that people report changes in.
比如生命的意义、生活的目的、所有人相互联系的程度，什么是人类生活和身为人类的普遍主题。这几乎是哲学问题，但由于人们面临的创伤，这些问题实际上变得具有现实意义。现在他们不得不，他们自然地开始重新思考：活着的意义是什么？我在这里的时间应该做些什么？提出这类问题并试图掌握如何生活得好且明智。所以这些通常是人们报告发生变化的五个领域。
And as I said before, any individual might be reporting post-traumatic growth in a way that's different from another individual because they're emphasizing one or more of these different areas. I understand that the spiritual change component of all that has been or is being expanded to be more inclusive of people who are not religious in the traditional sense. Is that true? That's right. We developed a measure of post-traumatic growth back in the mid-90s called the Post-Thrmatic Growth Inventory. And at that time, among the different items on this, the questions on the scale, there are really only two that had to do with this spiritual change factor. And they were pretty directly related to, I mean, one was specifically related to religion. And what we found in the intervening years is that especially in certain groups and in certain cultures and countries, people didn't really respond to that very much, maybe because it was a more secular kind of culture.
正如我之前所说，任何个人报告的创伤后成长方式可能都与他人不同，因为他们强调这五个不同领域中的一个或多个。我了解到，所有这些中的精神变化部分正在被扩展，以更具包容性，涵盖那些在传统意义上不信教的人。这是真的吗？没错。我们在90年代中期开发了一种衡量创伤后成长的量表，称为“创伤后成长量表”。在当时，量表上的不同项目和问题中，真正与这个精神变化因素相关的只有两个。它们与宗教的关系相当直接。我们在随后的几年里发现，特别是在某些群体和某些文化国家中，人们对这些问题的反应并不强烈，也许是因为那是一种更世俗的文化。
And so we did some more research. And this is about three years ago now, we added some other items, four more items to that scale to reflect these more existential kinds of questions. that I mentioned a few minutes ago, questions about meaning of life and death, meaning of the degree to which you are related to humanity, and there's a sense of connection among other human beings, these more existential sorts of questions that seem to dovetail with things that are spiritual and religious as well. So they kind of hold together into a group that we need. now call spiritual and existential change. Okay. And do you find that people who are religious
所以我们做了更多的研究。大约在三年前，我们在该量表中增加了一些其他项目，又增加了四个项目，以反映我几分钟前提到的那些更具存在主义性质的问题，关于生命和死亡意义的问题，关于你与人类联系程度的问题，以及人类之间存在的一种联系感，这些更具存在主义性质的问题似乎与精神和宗教方面的事物相吻合。所以它们结合成了一个我们现在称为“精神和存在主义变化”的群体。好的。你是否发现信教的人
experience post-dramatic growth more often than those who are not? There is evidence that that is the case, yes. And it may be that people who are religious might be more tuned into some of these existential questions than many people who are not religious. Okay. And are there certain types of trauma that people experience that may make them more likely to experience post-traumatic growth? Could it be natural disasters, the loss of a significant person in their life or a serious illness? We've looked at post-traumatic growth in relation to all kinds of different traumatic experiences. And what we've been struck by is that the process of growth seems to be very similar, no matter what the initial traumatic experience that is the impetus for growth may be.
比不信教的人更常经历创伤后成长？有证据表明确实如此。这可能是因为信教的人可能比许多不信教的人更关注这些存在主义问题。好的。人们经历的创伤类型是否会使他们更有可能经历创伤后成长？可能是自然灾害、生活中重要人物的离世或严重的疾病吗？我们研究了创伤后成长与各种不同创伤经历的关系。令我们震惊的是，无论作为成长动力的最初创伤经历是什么，成长的过程似乎都非常相似。
And the other thing about that, I think it's quite interesting. interesting is what is traumatic is really in the eye of the beholder. In psychology and psychiatry for many years, we've had the diagnostic and statistical manual, which kind of has defined what traumatic events are as a part of the definition of post-traumatic stress disorder. And we don't look at trauma the same way because we have found that many events that may not show up as sort of official DSM traumas have the same kind of effect in terms of producing post-traumatic growth because what's the common element is among all these events is if they shake
关于这一点，我认为还有一点非常有趣。什么是创伤，真的在于旁观者的眼中。在心理学和精神病学中，多年来我们一直有《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》，它将创伤事件定义为创伤后应激障碍定义的一部分。我们看待创伤的方式不同，因为我们发现许多可能不会表现为官方DSM创伤的事件，在产生创伤后成长方面具有同样的效果，因为所有这些事件的共同要素是，如果它们动摇了
the person's core belief system, if they challenge what people believe about who they are, what their future will hold, what kind of world they live in, the degree to which they have control over events, core beliefs like this, that. generally go unquestioned. If these things are challenged, we typically see down the road post-traumatic growth developing because people are grappling with those kinds of questions and reforming their belief system. And so no matter what the event might be that starts this process off, what's important is not the trauma itself. The trauma does not produce growth. It's what happens in the aftermath of trauma and what people are doing in response to the trauma.
一个人的核心信念系统，如果它们挑战了人们关于自己是谁、未来会怎样、生活在什么样的世界、对事件的控制程度等核心信念，这些通常不容置疑的信念。如果这些东西受到挑战，我们通常会看到创伤后成长在未来发展出来，因为人们正在努力解决这些问题并重塑他们的信念系统。所以无论开启这个过程的事件是什么，重要的不是创伤本身。创伤不会产生成长。重要的是创伤发生后发生了什么，以及人们如何应对创伤。
So we've not really focused so much on the particulars of the trauma as what happens once that trauma has occurred and what kinds of other events around people and how people are processing that trauma, thinking about it, and reaching conclusions about how to live now that they're in this, what they often call the new normal. Yeah, the reason I was thinking about all this is because when I was doing research for this topic, I noticed a lot of studies were on people who experienced natural disasters. And I was just curious why that group might be studied so much. And as I've been thinking about it, I'm wondering, and, you know, maybe you really want your take on this.
所以我们并没有真正关注创伤的细节，而是关注创伤发生后发生了什么，以及人们周围还有哪些其他事件，人们如何处理这些创伤，如何思考它，以及在他们现在处于这种他们常称之为“新常态”的状态下，如何得出关于如何生活的结论。是的，我之所以考虑所有这些，是因为在为这个主题做研究时，我注意到很多研究都是针对经历过自然灾害的人。我只是好奇为什么这个群体会被研究得这么多。正如我一直在思考的那样，我想知道，也许你真的想听听对此的看法。
Could that be because a natural disaster affects a broad swath of people at the same time? And it's a group that can be studied, you know, it's maybe easier to find a group of people who are impacted by a natural disaster. Is that the case? I think you've got it right there. You know, researchers, just like the rest of us, are constrained by, you know, time and cost. And, you know, if there's a natural disaster, it's kind of a, it's a natural experiment that has happened, right? So you can go right where the disaster has occurred. And like you say, you've got hundreds or thousands of people are all affected by the same kind of experience in sort of a general sense. And you've got a ready-made study group.
这是否因为自然灾害同时影响了广泛的人群？这是一个可以被研究的群体，你知道，找到一个受自然灾害影响的群体可能更容易。是这样吗？我想你说对了。你知道，研究人员和我们其他人一样，受到时间和成本的限制。而且，你知道，如果发生了自然灾害，这是一种已经发生的自然实验，对吧？所以你可以直接去灾害发生的地方。正如你所说，你有成百上千的人都受到同一种经历的影响，在某种普遍意义上。你有一个现成的研究小组。
So I think that's a big reason why this is often studied. And the other thing, of course, is that there is a lot of then similarity among the people that you're studying in terms of their experience. Of course, there's some differences in how much people have lost or how they've been hurt or whatever, but there's a lot of similarity then. So you're kind of controlling for what the trauma itself is. And when you have that kind of control or similarity,
所以我认为这是它经常被研究的一个重要原因。当然，另一件事是，你在研究的人群在他们的经历方面有很多相似之处。当然，人们损失了多少或受到了多大的伤害等方面存在一些差异，但总体上有很多相似之处。所以你实际上是在控制创伤本身是什么。当你拥有那种控制力或相似性时，
then you can trust your results a little bit more easily. Whereas if you look at other kinds, of other kinds of traumatic events, it may be harder to find people, harder to get people to cooperate with your study. So, for example, if you want to study or rape survivors, you know, that presents different kinds of challenges in order to locate those people and get them cooperating and reporting on their stories and whatnot. So I think it's a lot about logistics. Right. And like you said, it's like if people are in one geographic area and people, even though they were in a geographic area, there's probably a lot of different, obviously different
那么你就可以更容易地信任你的结果。而如果你观察其他类型的创伤事件，可能更难找到人，更难让人们配合你的研究。例如，如果你想研究强奸幸存者，你知道，为了定位这些人并让他们配合并报告他们的故事等等，这会带来不同类型的挑战。所以我认为这很大程度上与后勤有关。对。而且正如你所说，如果人们在一个地理区域，即使他们在一个地理区域，显然也有很多不同的
types of people in one location. It's kind of like a, you know, it's an easier group to study in some capacities. Yes. And also, I've been thinking a lot about this in terms of severe or terminal illnesses. And like you just mentioned before, that it's not the trauma necessarily. It's how, what people will do with it. But I'm just curious about how that, how post-traumatic growth plays in with a severe or terminal illness. And how being faced with impending death, might change someone's mindset because I was thinking about, as I was developing the questions, I was thinking about a neighbor of mine who passed away about 10 years ago, but he had terminal brain cancer. And though he was always a positive and good person to be around, I noticed he just
类型的人在同一个地方。在某些方面，这确实是一个更容易研究的群体。是的。此外，我一直在思考严重或绝症方面的问题。正如你刚才提到的，创伤本身并不重要。重要的是人们会用它做什么。但我只是好奇创伤后成长如何与严重或绝症相互作用。面对即将到来的死亡如何改变一个人的心态，因为我在构思问题时，想到了我的一位邻居，他在大约10年前去世了，但他患有晚期脑癌。虽然他一直是一个积极且容易相处的好人，但我注意到他只是
seemed to be so much more, I guess, like relishing life more is the term that comes to mind, just seemed like he was really enjoying what time he had. It wasn't very long, maybe a few years. But whenever I would see him, he would just be very positive and upbeat. I'm not, I, I don't know exactly, you know, the difficult things he faced. You know, I didn't live at home at the time. But, you know, I was very struck by his attitude and how he was, to me, seemed like he was really trying to make the most of what time he had left here. So do you, can you speak to how a terminal or severe illness might affect someone's mindset with post-traumatic growth?
似乎变得更加，我想，“享受生活”这个词浮现在脑海中，看起来他真的很享受他所拥有的时间。时间不长，也许几年。但每当我见到他时，他总是非常积极和乐观。我不知道他具体面临的困难。你知道，我当时不住在家里。但是，你知道，他的态度让我印象深刻，对我来说，他似乎真的在努力充分利用他剩下的时间。所以，您能谈谈绝症或严重疾病如何影响一个人的创伤后成长心态吗？
Well, of course, as I mentioned before, there are a lot of individual differences in how people respond to these events. So one person might respond to the diagnosis of a terminal illness with depression, a lot of anxiety. You know, it could be quite difficult. Another person might respond more like your neighbor did. Or there may be kind of a combination of those elements. But this is where maybe in your neighbor, as you're describing him, you're starting to see this aspect of appreciation of life. Maybe he was thinking, I only have a certain. amount of time left. I'm not sure exactly how much, but I'm going to make the most of it,
嗯，正如我之前提到的，人们对这些事件的反应存在很多个体差异。所以一个人可能会以抑郁、焦虑来应对绝症的诊断。你知道，这可能相当困难。另一个人可能会像你的邻居那样反应。或者这些因素可能有一种组合。但这就是为什么在你的邻居身上，正如你描述他的那样，你开始看到“对生活的欣赏”这一方面。也许他在想，我剩下的时间不多了。我不确定具体有多少，但我会充分利用它，
not be morose about it, not waste my time being depressed about things, but try to savor everything I have. It might have been that way of thinking about it that we call the appreciation of life as what you were seeing there. And so, yes, people who have diagnoses of serious illnesses that place their lives in jeopardy or get a diagnosis, which indicates they only have a short period time to live, may respond this way. Of course, that's not, again, universal, but we do see that. And, you know, there are reports of near-death experiences that people have where they have, you know, essentially died and been resuscitated, where, again, you get these reports of people being so grateful that they have a second chance at life or say they have some kind of what they see
不为此感到忧郁，不浪费时间为事情感到沮丧，而是试着细细品味我拥有的一切。可能就是那种我们称之为“对生活的欣赏”的思维方式，你所看到的就是那个。所以，是的，被诊断出患有危及生命的严重疾病或被诊断出只剩下很短时间的人，可能会以这种方式做出反应。当然，这再次强调，并非普遍现象，但我们确实看到了这一点。而且，你知道，有关于濒死体验的报道，人们基本上已经死亡并被复苏，在那里，你再次得到人们非常感激他们有第二次生命机会的报告，或者说他们对如何过好生活有某种他们所看到的
as a revelation about how to live life well because they've come so close to losing it. You know, this is perhaps one of the hallmarks of that particular kind of trauma where you get people who are, you know, close to death or have escaped death. And then they think about life in a different way and see it as more. precious. Is post-traumatic growth something that you can, is it something you can come to on your own or is it something that you need to be steered toward? Is that a little bit of both? It's both. You know, it's something that seems to come easier to some people than others, like we were talking about before, maybe has something to do with their pre-existing personality, maybe it has
启示，因为他们离失去它太近了。你知道，这也许是那种特定创伤的标志之一，你会遇到那些濒临死亡或逃脱死亡的人。然后他们以不同的方式思考生活，并将其视为更珍贵。创伤后成长是你自己可以达到的，还是需要有人引导你？是两者兼而有之吗？两者都有。你知道，这似乎对某些人来说比其他人更容易，就像我们之前谈到的，也许与他们预先存在的人格有关，也许与
something to do with the kind of cultural themes that you have been exposed to, the sort of stories you've heard, who you've seen around you, other people have been models or examples of how to respond to trauma in one of these positive ways. It can be all that might set people up for more or less post-traumatic growth. And certainly, as I mentioned at the outset too, the kind of support you get from people as you're going through this can make a big difference. We think that one part of this experience that seems to be important is to be able to talk it through, to be able to tell the story, to create the narrative that's emerging out of this experience where life is perhaps divided into a kind of a before and after these events
你所接触到的文化主题、你听到的故事、你周围看到的人、其他人作为如何以积极方式应对创伤的榜样或例子有关。所有这些都可能使人们产生或多或少的创伤后成长。当然，正如我在开头提到的，你在经历这一切时从人们那里得到的支持也会产生很大的影响。我们认为这种经历中似乎很重要的一部分是能够谈论它，能够讲述故事，创造出一种从这种经历中涌现出来的叙事，在这种叙事中，生活也许被划分为这些事件之前和之后，
and kind of be able to talk it through and figure out what's going on here and what kind of changes are happening in me and what am I going to do with all this? So having someone to disclose to about these things, a good listener, what my colleague Lawrence and I, Lawrence Calhoun and I have called the expert companions in these situations. This can make a big difference for many people. And just one more question I had about personalities because we were touching on this throughout our conversation. How does resiliency play into all this? Are resilient people more likely to experience dramatic growth? Well, resilience and post-traumatic growth are two different things. People who are resilient are relatively unaffected by events that are difficult. That's kind of the definition of
并且能够谈论它，弄清楚这里发生了什么，我身上发生了什么变化，我将如何处理这一切？所以有一个可以倾诉的对象，一个好的倾听者，我的同事劳伦斯·卡尔霍恩和我称之为这些情况下的“专家同伴”。这对许多人来说可以产生很大的影响。关于人格，我还有一个问题，因为我们在整个谈话中都触及了这一点。韧性在这一切中起什么作用？有韧性的人更有可能经历创伤后成长吗？嗯，韧性和创伤后成长是两回事。有韧性的人相对不受困难事件的影响。这基本上是
resilience. They're resistance to adversity or they bounce back quickly from adversity. Post-traumatic growth is something that happens after adversity has had a major effect on people so much that it challenges the core belief system, the basic and fundamental things that people really believe about themselves and their lives. So in that way, they're very different. And so the people who can, however, manage their emotional distress well enough so they can kind of think through this, have that type of what we might call resiliency, that is capability of managing their emotions in the aftermath of this can go through the thought processes that are involved in moving them towards growth. And eventually, people who experience post-traumatic growth
韧性的定义。他们对逆境有抵抗力，或者他们能从逆境中迅速恢复。创伤后成长是发生在逆境对人们产生重大影响之后，以至于挑战了核心信念系统，即人们真正相信的关于自己和生活的那些基本和根本的东西。所以从这个意义上说，它们非常不同。然而，那些能够很好地管理自己的情绪困扰，从而能够思考这个问题的人，拥有我们可能称之为“韧性”的那种能力，即在事后管理情绪的能力，可以经历那些促使他们走向成长的思维过程。最终，经历创伤后成长的人
should be more resilient in the future to other traumatic events that happen. So post-traumatic growth may be a pathway to resilience in some way, where people who go through this process learn better how to manage life and manage the things that are going to be happening to them in the future with a more resilient approach. So we can see post-traumatic growth is leading to resilience eventually. I want to turn now to talking about how you developed this theory with Dr. Calhoun. I read a Wall Street Journal article that said you pioneered this research while you were speaking with widows for a project. And in your research, you found that widows became close to to their children and more independent in the aftermath of the death of their spouses. Can you talk
在未来面对其他创伤事件时应该会更有韧性。所以创伤后成长在某种程度上可能是一条通往韧性的途径，经历这个过程的人学会了如何更好地管理生活，并以一种更具韧性的方式管理未来将要发生的事情。所以我们可以看到创伤后成长最终导致了韧性。现在我想转而谈谈你是如何与卡尔霍恩博士共同开发这个理论的。我读过一篇《华尔街日报》的文章，说你在与寡妇交谈进行一个项目时开创了这项研究。在你的研究中，你发现寡妇在配偶去世后与孩子变得亲近，并且更加独立。你能谈谈
about your findings and how that led you to developing this important theory? Well, we had been working with in a number of different ways. We had first thought about researching wisdom. That's what we were first interested in. This was back in the late 80s. And there wasn't much psychological literature on wisdom. So we started doing interviews with people who, we thought might have some wisdom. And the first group that we chose were people who had suffered physical disabilities in adulthood and had done particularly well. So we talked to people in our region who were able to find who were kind of remarkable examples of having gone through some terrible illnesses and accidents and doing very well. And so that was one group. Another group
你的发现以及它是如何引导你发展出这个重要理论的吗？嗯，我们一直在以多种不同的方式工作。我们最初考虑的是研究“智慧”。那是我们最初感兴趣的。那是在80年代末。关于智慧的心理学文献并不多。所以我们开始采访那些我们认为可能拥有某种智慧的人。我们选择的第一组人是那些在成年后遭受身体残疾但表现特别好的人。所以我们和我们地区能够找到的人交谈，他们是经历过一些可怕疾病和事故并做得非常好的杰出例子。所以那是第一组。另一组
were widows that you mentioned. We looked especially at older widows, people in there, generally their 70s and 80s, because we just made the common assumption that people are older or wiser. So we again, try to go for wisdom, and we talked to those people. And then at the time, I had been starting to work with bereaved parents in a nonprofit here in Charlotte. So I've been doing work for a couple years at that point, running support groups for bereaved parents, which I ended up doing for about 25 years. And just listening to the stories of these parents and being with them sometimes over a period of some years in these groups and seeing how they changed and how they talked about their experience, all these kinds of things led us into this area of post-traumatic
是你提到的寡妇。我们特别关注年长的寡妇，通常是70多岁和80多岁的人，因为我们只是做了一个普遍的假设，即人们越老越有智慧。所以我们再次尝试寻找智慧，并与这些人交谈。当时，我开始在夏洛特的一家非营利组织与丧亲父母一起工作。所以那时我已经做了几年工作，为丧亲父母举办支持小组，我最终做了大约25年。只是倾听这些父母的故事，有时在这些小组中陪伴他们几年，看到他们如何改变，以及他们如何谈论他们的经历，所有这些事情都引导我们进入了创伤后
growth because we kept hearing these themes. of these stories that people would say things like, I'm stronger than I thought I was, or something good has come out of this, or I see things differently I ever did before, or my relationships with people are better. I mean, people would report these things. And we took all these quotes that we had from our research studies and whatnot, and those quotations from people became items on our quantitative measurements, measure that we have used in our research since.
成长领域，因为我们不断听到这些故事的主题。人们会说类似这样的话：我比我想象的更坚强，或者从中产生了一些好的东西，或者我以与以前不同的方式看待事物，或者我与人的关系更好了。我的意思是，人们会报告这些事情。我们从我们的研究中获取了所有这些引语等等，人们的那些引语成为了我们定量测量中的项目，这是我们自那以后在研究中使用的测量方法。
Yeah, that's really fascinating. I love the idea of starting out talking about wisdom and how it led you to this. So it's a great trajectory to post-traumatic growth. Yeah, there's a lot of connections, of course, between post-traumatic growth and wisdom. You know, wisdom is a hard thing to measure, to define, in fact. You know, what exactly is that and what does it look like? And so people have been looking more at wisdom since the time that. that we started out, but we've focused not only on the outcomes of, you know, that we call post-traumatic growth, but the process, you know, how people get there, what they go through that creates these kinds of changes.
是的，这真的非常引人入胜。我很喜欢从探讨智慧开始，以及它是如何引导你走到这一步的。这是一个通往创伤后成长的绝佳轨迹。是的，当然，创伤后成长与智慧之间有很多联系。你知道，智慧其实是一个很难衡量、很难定义的东西。你知道，它到底是什么？它看起来是什么样的？所以，自从我们开始这项研究以来，人们对智慧的关注越来越多，但我们不仅关注我们所说的创伤后成长的结果，还关注其过程，也就是人们是如何达到这一点的，他们经历了什么才创造了这些改变。
And both those things are fascinating to us. The process in particular, because, you know, you mentioned earlier, you asked about, is it something natural or you need help in getting there? And from pretty early on in this work, we started considering how do we facilitate this process? How do we help people who are in the aftermath of trauma see that there's more to it than their misery and their loss? And so I think that learning from survives of trauma the ways that they have created for themselves and that have helped them move to towards growth has helped us to define some ways to kind of feed back to other trauma survivors. Here's how you might handle this. Here's what you might do.
这两者对我们来说都非常迷人。尤其是这个过程，因为你之前提到过，你问过这是自然发生的，还是需要帮助才能达到？在这项工作的早期，我们就开始考虑如何促进这个过程。我们如何帮助那些处于创伤余波中的人，让他们看到除了痛苦和损失之外，还有更多的东西？所以我认为，向创伤幸存者学习他们为自己创造的方法，以及那些帮助他们走向成长的方法，已经帮助我们定义了一些可以反馈给其他创伤幸存者的方法。这就是你可能处理这种情况的方式。这就是你可能做的事情。
Here's how you might want to think through this. Here are the kind of people you want to be around. Giving people some ideas that can move them from just mere survival to something that makes this whole experience. a valuable one, even if the experience itself was not something that they would want to repeat. So what purpose do you think post-traumatic growth might serve in us as humans? You know, is it maybe making sense of a chaotic and unfair world, or is it something deeper? Well, I think that, and I'm not sure if this has been designed by evolution or God, but I can say that one of the most...
这就是你可能想要思考的方式。这就是你想要与之相处的人。给人们一些想法，让他们从仅仅是生存转变为让整个经历变得有价值，即使这种经历本身并不是他们想要重复的。那么，你认为创伤后成长作为人类可能起到什么作用呢？你知道，它是在理解一个混乱和不公平的世界，还是更深层次的东西？嗯，我认为，我不确定这是进化还是上帝设计的，但我可以说，其中最...
important outcomes of post-traumatic growth that serves not only the individual but the species, I guess we could say, is the service that sometimes comes out of this growth experience, which is a benefit to other people in the family and the community, even in the nation. Lessons are learned and are distributed beyond the trauma survivor. So, for example, one of the things that I've been doing lately is work with a veterans retreat center called Boulder Crest Retreat. And we've developed a program based on post-traumatic growth for combat veterans. And the last thing that we do in our retreats is we help people start to define what their next mission will be. and veterans, of course, understand the concept of mission because it's a military word.
创伤后成长的重要成果，不仅服务于个人，也可以说是服务于物种，那就是这种成长经历有时会带来的服务，这对家庭、社区甚至国家中的其他人都有益处。经验教训被学习并传播给创伤幸存者之外的人。例如，我最近一直在做的一件事是与一个名为“博尔德克雷斯特静修处”（Boulder Crest Retreat）的退伍军人静修中心合作。我们为战斗退伍军人开发了一个基于创伤后成长的项目。我们在静修中做的最后一件事是帮助人们开始定义他们的下一个使命是什么。当然，退伍军人理解使命这个概念，因为这是一个军事术语。
It's a mission of service. You know, who are they going to be in their communities as people who have learned some hard lessons about life and death and can be a positive force in their community as a result of the hard lessons that they have learned? So post-traumatic growth can lead people on these missions. because they understand something about living life and the value of it, living life well, and the importance of it, and act as maybe our social conscience, our coaches and encouragers, people who have something to impart to maybe the rest of us who have not seen what they have seen. And so we think about that program at Boulder Crest, what we call our warrior path program, as a way to eventually have a social impact beyond just healing these warriors from PTSD, but helping them find a new purpose in being of service in a way that impacts people beyond themselves. So ultimately I see post-traumatic growth as having that kind of effect on people. So, for example, going back to your neighbor that had the terminal illness, it might be that
这是一种服务的使命。你知道，作为那些学到了一些关于生与死的深刻教训的人，他们将在社区中成为什么样的人？由于他们学到的深刻教训，他们能成为社区中的一股积极力量吗？所以创伤后成长可以引导人们执行这些使命，因为他们了解一些关于生活和它的价值、好好生活以及它的重要性的东西，并可能充当我们的社会良知、我们的教练和鼓励者，为我们这些没有见过他们所见之物的人提供一些东西。因此，我们认为博尔德克雷斯特的那个项目，也就是我们所说的“勇士之路”项目，是一种最终产生社会影响的方式，不仅仅是治愈这些患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的勇士，而是帮助他们找到一种新的目标，以一种影响自身之外的人的方式去服务。所以最终，我认为创伤后成长对人们有这种影响。所以，例如，回到你那位患有绝症的邻居身上，可能是...
his way of interacting with you, his example of how he was living life, may have had some degree of influence on how you think and what you do. I mean, you obviously remember him. And you remember him in a way which shows that you can. consider his way of living as being an inspiration to you in some sense of the word, perhaps. And maybe he had some impact on how you go about your life as well. So people who are trauma survivors can serve that function for us. Yeah, absolutely.
他与你互动的方式，他如何生活生活的榜样，可能对你的想法和行为产生了一定程度的影响。我的意思是，你显然记得他。你以一种表明你可以将他的生活方式在某种意义上视为对你的启发的方式记住他。也许他对你如何过自己的生活也有一些影响。所以创伤幸存者可以为我们发挥这种作用。是的，绝对是这样。
That's a really beautiful way of putting it. I mean, like you said, it's something I remember very vividly. And, you know, I hope to keep that with me as I go through life and think about, okay, he really seemed like he was taking advantage of the time he had. So I do try to remember that. I want to ask a question about your work with Boulder Cress in a recent book you co-authored about post-traumatic growth among members of the military. So as you know, and I'm sure many of our listeners know, the lens in which military veterans are looked at is often in the post-traumatic stress disorder lens. And the book, the chapter talked about how
这真是一种非常美妙的表达方式。我的意思是，就像你说的，这是我记忆非常深刻的事情。而且，你知道，我希望在我经历人生的过程中能一直保持这一点，并思考，好吧，他真的看起来是在充分利用他拥有的时间。所以我确实试着记住这一点。我想问一个关于你与博尔德克雷斯特合作的问题，以及你最近合著的一本关于军队成员创伤后成长的书。所以正如你所知，我相信我们的许多听众也知道，看待退伍军人的视角通常是创伤后应激障碍的视角。而那本书的章节谈到了如何...
In only in a recent decade, some of the focus has shifted to post-traumatic growth. So can you talk about that chapter you wrote and how that applies to your work with Boulder Crest? Well, we, I've done a lot of my work at Boulder Crest with Brett Moore, who is a psychologist in San Antonio, who was an Army psychologist and was deployed in Afghanistan and is now at Brook Army Medical Center in their resilience program there. And Brett and I have been trying to describe military veterans in kind of another light than the light in which they've often been seen. The assumption that many people have about veterans is that they come back from combat, if not physically disabled, emotionally disabled by their combat experiences, traumatized in terrible ways. And then they're often by the mental health professionals labeled with post-traumatic stress disorder. Note the term disorder.
在最近十年里，一些焦点已经转移到了创伤后成长上。那么你能谈谈你写的那个章节以及它如何应用于你与博尔德克雷斯特的工作吗？嗯，我在博尔德克雷斯特的大部分工作都是与布雷特·摩尔（Brett Moore）一起完成的，他是圣安东尼奥的一位心理学家，曾是陆军心理学家，被派往阿富汗，现在在布鲁克陆军医疗中心的复原力项目中工作。布雷特和我一直试图以一种不同于人们通常看待退伍军人的视角来描述他们。许多人对退伍军人的假设是，他们从战斗中回来，如果不是身体残疾，就是因战斗经历而情绪受损，以可怕的方式受到创伤。然后他们经常被心理健康专业人员贴上创伤后应激障碍的标签。注意“障碍”这个词。
What we have emphasized is that these are human beings who are not disordered, that they have responded to terrible events in a human way. It's not what's wrong with them. It's what's happened to them. And so we are trying to take that kind of term disorder out of the equation and focus instead on what these people have learned from their experience and how it's changed them into people who have to face up to the fundamental existential questions of life and death. If we can help them process that, they're going to be some of the wiser people among us, perhaps, instead of people who have to just be medicated and put on disability or something of that sort. They can be of great use and purpose in our civilian world having come through what they've come through,
我们强调的是，这些人不是有障碍的人，他们是以一种人类的方式对可怕的事件做出了反应。这不是他们有什么问题，而是他们经历了什么。所以我们试图把“障碍”这个词从等式中剔除，转而关注这些人从他们的经历中学到了什么，以及它如何将他们改变成必须面对生与死的基本存在主义问题的人。如果我们能帮助他们处理这些问题，他们可能会成为我们中间更有智慧的人，而不是那些只需要服药并被列为残疾或类似情况的人。在经历了他们所经历的一切之后，他们可以在我们的平民世界中发挥巨大的作用和目的，
that we can repurpose their military training and experience for important missions in civilian life. So that's a post-traumatic growth kind of lens that we're trying in these situations, that out of traumatic events can come positive and valuable changes. But again, we have to sometimes find ways to encourage those kinds of changes and to help people see things through this lens. We find it very poignant when we introduced to these combat veterans in our programs, that basic concept of you are not broken and it's not what's wrong with you. It's what happened to you.
我们可以将他们的军事训练和经验重新用于平民生活中的重要使命。所以这是一种我们试图在这些情况下使用的创伤后成长的视角，即创伤事件可以带来积极和有价值的改变。但同样，我们有时必须找到鼓励这些改变的方法，并帮助人们通过这个视角看待事物。当我们向项目中的这些战斗退伍军人介绍“你没有崩溃，这不是你有什么问题，而是你经历了什么”这一基本概念时，我们发现这非常令人心酸。
Lightbulbs start going off for these people, you know, because they've been labeled and thought of in a very different way. And we remind them that, you know, they are people. who have futures that are of value and we need to help them find a way towards that future and those values. So this is the basis for the program at Boulder Crest, this post-dient growth philosophy. We find that people, you know, respond to it very positively. I mean, you know, many people say to us, you know, no one's ever talked to us about this
这些人的灯泡开始亮了，你知道，因为他们被贴上了标签，并以一种非常不同的方式被看待。我们提醒他们，你知道，他们是人，拥有有价值的未来，我们需要帮助他们找到通往那个未来和那些价值观的道路。这就是博尔德克雷斯特项目的基础，这种创伤后成长的哲学。我们发现人们，你知道，对此反应非常积极。我的意思是，你知道，许多人对我们说，你知道，从来没有人跟我们谈过这个...
before. They've just talked to us about our symptoms. They've never talked to us about anything else. Why haven't anybody mentioned this to us before? So we say, well, it's because, you know, this has been the sort of the philosophy and the lens through which mental health has been practicing for a long time, sort of a medical model that, you know, people are coming in sick and we have to cure them. But we're approaching this from a different kind of perspective of core belief challenge that can lead to. people on a process of discovery. I think that's a really important way you just framed everything.
以前。他们只是跟我们谈论我们的症状。他们从来没有跟我们谈论过其他任何事情。为什么以前没有人向我们提到过这一点？所以我们说，嗯，这是因为，你知道，这长期以来一直是心理健康实践的哲学和视角，这是一种医疗模式，你知道，人们生病了进来，我们必须治愈他们。但我们正从一种不同的核心信念挑战的视角来处理这个问题，这可以引导人们走上发现的过程。我认为你刚才对一切的框架方式非常重要。
And it's really shifted the way I've been looking at it too. Like you said, if you're looking at the disorder, the word itself, what does that mean? How does it apply to people? And how that's just part of our vernacular. That's how we often approach military veterans is that, you know, you're dealing with someone who, like you said, that someone's broken as opposed to someone who is dealing with a very difficult traumatic situation in some circumstances. in a very human way. So I think that the way you're framing it at the Boulder Crest Institute is really
这也确实改变了我看待它的方式。就像你说的，如果你看“障碍”这个词本身，那是什么意思？它如何应用于人们？这只是我们白话的一部分。我们通常接近退伍军人的方式是，你知道，你正在处理一个像你所说的那样，某人崩溃了，而不是一个在某些情况下正在以非常人性化的方式处理非常困难的创伤情况的人。所以我认为你在博尔德克雷斯特研究所的框架方式确实...
tremendous. And I think that's that will have a big impact on how we as a country and, you know, beyond that, look at people who go into combat, whether they're still in service or whether they're a veteran. I am not a military person. I've never served in the military, but being involved with this population and seeing how they respond to a program based on these principles has been a remarkable thing for me and has validated a lot of the research work that we've done over some decades to see how this starts to really work when it's the basis of a program like this. So it's greatly satisfying and it applies to all kinds of trauma survivors and work that I've done in my own clinical practice,
非常了不起。我认为这将对我们作为一个国家，以及在此之外，看待那些参加战斗的人产生重大影响，无论他们是在服役还是退伍军人。我不是军人。我从未在军队服役，但参与这个群体并看到他们如何对基于这些原则的项目做出反应对我来说是一件了不起的事情，并且验证了我们在过去几十年中所做的大量研究工作，看看当它成为这样一个项目的基础时，它是如何真正开始发挥作用的。所以这非常令人满意，它适用于各种创伤幸存者，以及我在自己的临床实践中所做的工作，
you know, I've seen how this kind of approach and this sort of perspective can really encourage people to look at their experience and their futures in a much more optimistic way and ultimately a realistic way. So we're trying to get the word out, and I'm glad that you're doing this podcast with me so that other people can hear about it. Are there parallels to research about police officers? Because I did find a little bit of research about how, again, this population has been looked at, focused under the lens of post-traumatic stress.
你知道，我已经看到这种方法和这种视角如何真正鼓励人们以一种更乐观、最终更现实的方式看待他们的经历和未来。所以我们正在努力传播这个消息，我很高兴你和我一起做这个播客，这样其他人也能听到它。关于警察的研究是否有相似之处？因为我确实找到了一些关于这个群体如何再次被看待的研究，重点是在创伤后应激的视角下。
What do you think about post-traumatic growth for this particular population and other first responders who deal with traumatic situations on the job? Absolutely. Police officers, firefighters, EMTs. You know, my clinical work, I've worked with all those groups. And at Boulder Crest, we also include first responders in our programs. So there's a lot of similarity between what happens in combat and what happens with a lot of first responders in terms of what they see and how trauma is a unfortunately natural and fairly common aspect of their job performance. And so a lot of this applies to that group as well, as well as other people like physicians, for example, or attorneys. I mean, nurses, I mean, there are just a lot of groups of people who, even teachers, social
你如何看待这个特定群体以及其他在工作中处理创伤情况的急救人员的创伤后成长？绝对的。警察、消防员、急救人员。你知道，我的临床工作，我与所有这些群体都合作过。在博尔德克雷斯特，我们的项目中也包括急救人员。所以战斗中发生的事情与许多急救人员在他们所见以及创伤如何不幸地成为他们工作表现中自然且相当普遍的方面之间有很多相似之处。所以这很多也适用于那个群体，以及其他像医生或律师这样的人。我的意思是，护士，我的意思是，有很多群体，甚至教师、社会...
workers, psychologists. Yeah. We've done studies of psychologists and clergy. So there are people who are exposed to trauma all the time. Trauma is a common experience in the whole population of human beings. So one way or the other, we're going to be affected. Yeah, it's very fascinating. name to when you talk about all the different groups of people who, you know, work with people
工作者、心理学家。是的。我们对心理学家和神职人员进行了研究。所以有些人一直暴露在创伤中。创伤是整个人类群体中的一种普遍经历。所以无论如何，我们都会受到影响。是的，这非常迷人。当你谈论所有那些与经历过创伤情况的人一起工作的不同群体时，这很有名。
who have been through traumatic situations. Is that what's known as vicarious trauma if you are, it may not happening to you directly, but you are a witness to it? Yes. And so what we've researched what we call vicarious post-traumatic growth. Oh, interesting. Can you talk about that a bit? So, you know, being around trauma survivors and helping trauma survivors, some of it rubs off on you, we could say. I mean, you learn some lessons by helping other people. I feel like that's happened with me in helping trauma survivors during my career. I feel like it's changed some of my perspective and ways of understanding people and living human life, living my own life. So if you listen carefully and you're close, some of these things you see and you hear can help you
如果不是直接发生在你身上，但你是见证者，这被称为替代性创伤吗？是的。所以我们研究了我们所说的替代性创伤后成长。哦，有趣。你能谈谈那个吗？所以，你知道，与创伤幸存者在一起并帮助创伤幸存者，其中一些会影响到你，我们可以这样说。我的意思是，你通过帮助别人学到了一些教训。我觉得在我的职业生涯中帮助创伤幸存者时，这种情况发生在我身上。我觉得它改变了我的一些视角以及理解人们和过人类生活、过我自己生活的方式。所以如果你仔细听并且你很亲近，你看到和听到的一些事情可以帮助你...
start to rethink some of your own perspectives on these areas of post-trained growth that I mentioned. Wow, that's really fascinating. One last question as we wrap up today, for our listeners who may be dealing with the aftermath of a tragedy or have some of their life who's going through such a thing, what might they be able to do to increase the likelihood that they would experience the positive changes associated with post-traumatic growth? Well, one thing is make sure that they don't numb or avoid their emotional life in the aftermath of what's happened. emotions are important sources of information about how these events are affecting us and we need to kind of invite some of that emotional reaction rather than numb it so if your primary care physician wants to give you medication which makes you feel numbed out and zombie like it's probably not going to be helpful in the long run for post-traumatic growth although it might feel good initially
开始重新思考你自己在这些我提到的创伤后成长领域的一些观点。哇，这真的非常迷人。在我们今天结束之前，最后一个问题，对于那些可能正在处理悲剧余波或生活中有人正在经历这种事情的听众，他们可以做些什么来增加他们经历与创伤后成长相关的积极改变的可能性？嗯，有一件事是确保他们在所发生的事情之后不会麻木或回避他们的情感生活。情绪是关于这些事件如何影响我们的重要信息来源，我们需要邀请一些这种情绪反应，而不是麻木它，所以如果你的初级保健医生想给你开药，让你感到麻木和像僵尸一样，从长远来看，这对创伤后成长可能不会有帮助，尽管它最初可能感觉很好。
and you have to be open to thinking about what all this means for you. And it's important to find an expert companion. Somebody that you can talk to and trust is going to be there for the long haul with you. Some people are lucky to have those folks in their family or friends, among their family or friends. But some people need to find somebody else to talk to. They're a clergy person, a mental health person. But somebody who has this sort of perspective that they're not disordial. that they're human beings that are challenged by trauma and that there's something in this
你必须对思考这一切对你意味着什么持开放态度。找到一个专家同伴很重要。一个你可以交谈并信任会长期陪伴你的人。有些人很幸运在他们的家人或朋友中拥有这些人。但有些人需要找到其他人来交谈。他们是神职人员、心理健康人员。但某人有这种视角，他们不是有障碍的。他们是受到创伤挑战的人类，并且其中有一些东西...
that's worth examining closely to help them figure out how to move forward in a constructive way and to think of themselves as somewhat of value who has something perhaps to say, something to offer other people who are struggling in their lives, to find a way to be of service. So those are some things to keep in mind. And Brett Moore and I, we put together a workbook, a post-traumatic growth workbook. That's a guide for people. They can get the workbook and they can use that to help them take the steps that we think are important and working through this process to live in a way that optimizes this post-traumatic growth that we've described.
值得仔细检查，以帮助他们弄清楚如何以建设性的方式前进，并将自己视为有价值的人，也许对生活中正在挣扎的其他人有一些话要说，有一些东西可以提供，找到一种服务的方式。所以这些是需要记住的事情。布雷特·摩尔和我，我们整理了一本工作手册，一本创伤后成长工作手册。这是人们的指南。他们可以得到这本工作手册，并利用它来帮助他们采取我们认为在处理这个过程中很重要的步骤，以一种优化我们所描述的这种创伤后成长的方式生活。
Thank you so much for joining us today, Dr. Tideski. It's been a really wonderful conversation. I think will be very helpful for people who, as I mentioned, maybe gone through a traumatic situation, have someone in their life who is, or you just have something keep in there in mind for the future. Well, I've enjoyed it very much, and I appreciate your thought-provoking questions,
非常感谢你今天加入我们，泰德斯基博士。这是一次非常美妙的谈话。我认为这对那些正如我所提到的，可能经历过创伤情况、生活中有人正在经历这种情况，或者你只是在未来记住一些事情的人非常有帮助。嗯，我很享受它，我很欣赏你发人深省的问题，
and I hope that your listeners benefit from our conversation. Absolutely. Thank you so much. Before we end this episode, just a reminder that we want to hear from you, You can email your comments and ideas to Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, dot org. And please give us a rating in iTunes. It really helps. You can find all previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on Apple, Stitcher, Spotify,
我希望你的听众能从我们的谈话中受益。绝对的。非常感谢。在我们结束这一集之前，提醒一下我们想听听你的意见，你可以通过电子邮件将你的评论和想法发送到 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。那是 Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，点 org。请在 iTunes 上给我们评分。这真的很有帮助。你可以在 Apple、Stitcher、Spotify 上找到所有以前的 Speaking of Psychology 剧集，
or wherever you get your podcast. You can also go to our website, speakingof psychology.org. I'm Caitlin Luna with the American Psychological Association. Thanks for listening. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
或者任何你获取播客的地方。你也可以访问我们的网站，speakingof psychology.org。我是美国心理学会的凯特琳·卢纳（Caitlin Luna）。感谢收听。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。